you
hello oh hello mass be Terry a vowel
please speaking oh hello my name is Adam
Smith calling from nobelprize.org the
website of the Nobel Prize in Stockholm
aha we have a tradition of recording
very short interviews with new lawyers
could we speak for just a couple of
minutes of call here thank you very much
for first of all congratulations on the
order the Nobel Prize thank you thank
you very much what what were you doing
when the call from Stockholm came I was
sleeping it's two o'clock so it's
traditionally to sleep here did you wake
up enough to realize what was happening
immediately everyone say my wife's I did
it once I had the phone they realized
that it could gather a Franco a call
from the committee and and what was your
first reaction on hearing the news I
will really really happy it must be very
nice to be linked together with Martin
Karplus and a particularly Michael
Levitt with whom you've worked so
closely yes particularly with Mike yes
because you you to follow quite similar
paths traveling around and collaborating
very closely yes since the late 60s will
travel a lot and we'll really good
friend you're part of quite an
extraordinary scientific family tree
that you were for instance a postdoc in
mike martin karplus his lab and he
worked with linus pauling so it sort of
goes back doesn't it also my PhD mentor
look forward peter debye indeed indeed
indeed and do you think all that matters
do you think it's all very important in
pushing one in the one in the right
direction not in my case because I I
never know which direction to take so
stages a when when we move to do
c8 if you 75 it helped to push in one
direction but originally a I'm not sure
so we just spoke to Michael Levitt and
he was saying how people still don't
really realize how important computers
are in science not just in sort of
analysis but in experimentation a
correct they not only don't not realize
they essentially external some of them
have strong objections at them they
believe that the computers could be used
only to movies but not to understand
major there is a major difficulty to see
that this is the best tool we have
molecules are working and and so do you
think that the award of the Nobel Prize
will help promote the cause if you like
absolutely i think that liking the field
of understanding enzymes a extremely
convenient to ignore careful
computations but once you get their
notoriety it will become much clearer
that this is ike keep writing it's the
best tool and what really happened
inside the biological molecule yes so i
think it will help enormously thank you
thank you and then so may i just ask you
who are you proudest about telling the
news too i think my wife but she heard
it before me and nope i think just my
family yeah that's it is fine that's
about the user ok thank you so much once
again congratulations and i hope you
have a wonderful day thank you thank you
very much thank you back bye
you